The war is over.
You know,
most of us have given up most of our
privacy already.
If you are giving your all of your
financial disclosures online,
your credit card,
your social security and so forth,
I think the way we protect those things
can afford us the ability to protect our
medical records as well.
It's moving in this direction.
In fact,
a one would say there is almost a moral
obligation for people to begin to
disclose at least a portion of their
medical records online because it's only
through that disclosure on a large
scale,
uh,
whether it's,
you're not your necessarily your name
and your identity,
but at least you're finish.
You're phenotypical data and your
genomic data will allow us to create a
whole revolution in personalized and
preventative medicine,
which I think is a,
which is extraordinarily important for
the next few decades.
We are testing what it is like to lose
privacy.
Now the loss of privacy inherent in
these technologies is a precursor to an
almost biological or extra sensory loss
of privacy that will come as the species
evolves.
Shame that could be used to control us,
will no longer be able to control us
because we'll find out that everybody
masturbates or everybody has this kind
of sex with their,
with their spouse,
or eat this kind of food or picks their
nose or does whatever.
A lot of taboo won't be taboo anymore.
And that,
which is truly taboo will
kind of rise to the surface in a way.
And we'll see what we all can kind of
agree that we don't want to do this.
If the species survives,
um,
we'll,
we'll develop that sort of organismic
capability and we won't be able to be
embarrassed by that stuff anymore.